we do we don't need them because we do
no because they're lesbians who do you
who do you call to get your car fixed a
man or a woman your toilet breaks down
who do you call so I fix my own car your
power supply who runs it who runs the
infrastructure of society men or women
oh at the moment obviously because
patriarchy I'm obsessed with being a
woman in a male dominated industry I do
all of my own carpentries
right but but regardless of that like
you agree that men run the
infrastructure so therefore yeah men
around the world so that we need men on
a wider scale yes yeah the wider scale
on a personal scale no because you don't
need a man to provide for you we need
men to run the industries that Keep Us
Alive and Well not necessarily no so
because I know female mechanics
Engineers remember remember that's
exception like those Industries are like
99 male yeah but for now and we can
change that do we want to change that